[Music]
hey welcome to every damn day its season
two of every damn day it's Thursday so
that means we're going inside the comedy
central vault which is a phrase that we
stole from Disney and where do I look at
some content today's topic is what is
the best key and Peele sketch of all
time it's possibly the best sketch show
of all time and we're gonna look at
which single sketch rises to the top
this first pic comes from Ryan mrs.
east-west college ball to various news
king merrimack college town Royals
smoochie-wallace university Miami this
query is green jr. University of Notre
Dame ibrahim moizoos university of
tennessee at chattanooga jack marius
tech there at Rick's Michigan State
University the Isaiah tee buildings
climb Coastal Carolina University the
Jets were probing truck to the 3rd South
Carolina State University leoz maxwell
Julian Heath Carolina University
Jabbar's to Marge Morrison Lamar
University of Middle Tennessee so funny
Ryan why did you picked out why because
this is about the best key & peele
sketch and that's what this shows about
and shows over folks that's the best one
it's so much so funny i watch it once a
year it doesn't get old because football
players keep having crazy names it's
like as someone who tries to write
comedy it is so frustrating that it's
like oh just like silly names said in a
funny way is the funniest the funniest
thing it's the funniest thing farting is
another funny thing that's always funny
but this one I want to give a big shout
out to the real football players that
probably inspired this ha ha Clinton
dicks
fabious Mingo D'Brickashaw Ferguson that
one I'm fine with I think that's a
regular name where I come from so yeah
Davis Mingo my dream was to literally
give to the NFL and say my high school
didn't say my elementary school about in
my third year
you played football in high school
growing up so I'm gonna give you your
chance right now do it how would you say
it Christian Smith elementary school all
right let's watch this next clip this
was Hannah's pic this is Georgina and
Esther and say oh I have nothing but
nothing every creature on this planet
but he don't let my darling Krystal go
I'm gonna flirt with the devil oh oh
show me little bit of shoulder how you
doing
he gonna start looking around what start
twerking start whittling away he's gonna
be he gonna be drawn in seduce a little
then when he least expects it and I got
his trust that's when I'm gonna ride I'm
gonna give him the night of his life
and I ain't never gonna forget you don't
give him this way come on give him that
way right wing he about to climax that's
when I'm with a divine Kegel with your
pants with your brain swinging of course
but the praise yeah Wow why do you like
about that place I mean I'm a huge Tyler
Perry fan as well so that but also I'm
from Virginia and people too I mean they
don't talk about God like that and I
guess they're talking about the devil
but they speak so real in terms of like
real they do with God so it's like
yeah what it makes me think of is I grew
up religious I went to a United
Methodist Church I go to a youth group
every Sunday and all of my first sexual
experiences we're at the church
[Laughter]
I was like oh no the devil is getting me
a handjob my most religious friends were
the biggest freaks yeah it's like I'm
like you every Sunday they'd go to
church and then there was always the
first to give a blowjob I was like
alright maybe I should give this a shot
alright this one comes to us from Chris
is your pick mm-hmm it's a great one
dueling hacks oh you know cuz keepin it
straight
i cou well I guess I'll check you later
alright dot rain people with James Caan
yeah man um how Denise Oh
anyway guess I'll catch you on the flip
yeah okay I'm in New York took it look
I'm talking in E and I'm in your dog I'm
in your dog I'm in there dog no no so
good what do you like about that one
I love how settle it was but honest and
true in it
listen to do the hats in high school
ridiculous it was it was like this is it
they will kind of make it look so fresh
don't even weird what do you guys go to
to fill your sketch comedy void now that
you don't watch key and Peele on the air
I watch them a good doctor to scratch
your sketch comedy is it hard bro like I
don't think I would care that much it's
got these funny sketches about people
having heart attacks and it's so
aggressive and I'm like Sydney like is
that the doctor show where the guy has
like I like you because
no I love it I love the Betty he does
he's autistic doctor and it is great the
best kind no honestly he is because he's
so focused and super focused and it's
like a superpower man in the focus group
testing they did the name autistic
doctor didn't play as well as good
doctor this is my into the competition
my favorite key and peele sketch is
Undercover Boss check this out
I'm not actually a new employee you can
say that again you a waste of space as
far as I'm concerned
can't you another done in time like I
said like a snail over here I am
actually president of the company
you're on Undercover Boss this week
since I've been working here amongst you
I got to hear each and every one of your
stories just about and I know is this
playing right you know I just trying to
lighten the mood in the workplace and
why not okay Thank You Joseph bill buddy
you're telling me that your car broke
down and it hasn't been working right
ever since well I want to get you a new
Ford Explorer oh thank you so much mark
that means so much to me the whole
family died in one day
thank you huge car crash huge man we
were having a family picnic and in his
truck just came on through and just
killing everybody it champa everybody as
well true and honest they play it and
just whenever a sketch has an emotional
turn like that or you just see a
character like that's my favorite like I
worked in a warehouse I packaged
lawnmower blades it was like one of my
first jobs they do that for like a year
and we were horrible horrible to people
at the warehouse we had a new employee
we just hazed and terrorized like it was
just like a feeding frenzy I mean you
just like rip on whoever's there because
it's like you're making like $7 an hour
there's nothing to do but insult each
other just terrorizing people and then
it's like absolutely
that's what happens definitely mommy
when I used to work at UPS plus I watch
Undercover Boss
yeah alright I used to not like wants to
bring the tears out when he when they do
that turn where it's like to you and you
I that yeah I know one of your kids is
missing a limb right fifteen
multicolored limbs and you like would
you want Undercover Boss was revealed
today like what would you want as a gift
well that's funny that you say that
because I've been meaning to tell
everybody I'm actually the president of
comedies no yeah I have been the
president I just want to say you guys
are all doing a great job but it's up to
you then to decide and your infinite
wisdom what is the best key in pills I'm
going with the one that I picked from
the president the winner is east west
college doing aunt Hannah do you have a
shout out for us I do have a shout out
this is from my yesterday's episode
where they asked what is the most adult
vape flavor and and Matthew Messer said
Prozac and coffee so we're gonna keep
the theme of the vault going and Ryan
actually interviewed the Comedy Central
stand-up comic Tim Dylan you're gonna
watch that right hey I'm Ryan Beck I'm
here with Tim Dylan you can catch his
Comedy Central half-hour this Friday at
11:00 we're about to play a game called
before or after Tim thanks for joining
me thank you so much it was compulsory
yeah do you know how to play this game I
think I do
well I'll explain it to everybody here
I'm gonna say something and then I'm
gonna say is this before or after
something else and then you decide
sounds very simple almost on the edge of
stupid
that's what we're doing here first up
John Stewart's first time hosting the
daily show Republicans want to call
Monica Lewinsky to the stand as well as
any other women Clinton may have had
affairs with however many officials
oppose the idea saying the caravan of
trailer homes to Washington to paralyze
interstate traffic and robbed the Little
Rock fast-food industry of hundreds of
its most reliable assistant managers was
this before or after the Backstreet Boys
hit I want it that way
after that's incorrect really really Jon
Stewart January 11th 1999 Backstreet
Boys April 12 1999 that's so close it's
very close yeah I didn't realize it was
a photo finish that every question was
going to be okay but I'm wrong on that
what this does is it really makes me
feel smart
yeah cuz I have the question I didn't
realize it we were trying to make people
lose but good just went ahead yeah
that'll make people want to watch my
special make me look like a fool Friday
at 11:00 our next statement is the last
episode of dr. Katz professional
therapist yes but was this before or
after the debut of Comedy Central's
premium blend the stand-up show what are
you doing son oh I'm just trying on
these new boots Stan
hi mom hi dad
I thought premium blend was on in the
1950s that was my a lot of the comedians
I know from Long Island have done
premium blend and they're in their mid
eighties whatever the question is other
than it was yes you're correct rehab was
always gonna be before whatever the
question yeah premium button what was
the first thing on television yeah it
was literally the first signal sent out
from the military on TV your next one
yeah Crank Yankers debut hello hello
lady no I'm a man take me out to the
ballgame yeah yay ballgames
did it debut on Comedy Central before or
after Dave Thomas from Wendy's died oh
oh oh God before Crank Yankers was after
yes Dave Thomas never got to see the
puppets making fake code after Dave
Thomas died history stop yet for me I
stopped paying attention yep to anything
big mob but what is it a month what is a
no actually with six months so Dave
Thomas died I take full responsibility
moderator ass chicken sandwich the
nineties version amazing the new version
disgusting it has gotten worse and I
don't know first no one's talking about
it everybody's talking about a lot of
other things you know what nobody else
is talking about you know that building
if you look at New York City and you
look there's that one that's just a
square it has a flat top it's like the
tallest residential building you know
I'm talking about do you see it from
where yeah when I come over the bridge
up from my brain I pour yeah
then I go look at that ugly building
over there with you I think the
aesthetic is kind of a crust yeah yeah
go by exactly Kennedy used to complain
about stuff like that she died and then
nobody has replaced her there's no civic
virtue anymore amongst a ruling class
something that I discuss all the time
and she died before Crank Yankers debut
yes she did she would have loved it she
would have loved Crank Yankers to round
it out the roast of Pamela Anderson was
this was a great I was
very funny Oh Pam Anderson wouldn't be
anyone without her tits that's just not
true it's not true she'd be Paris Hilton
before or after Hulu was launched oh it
has to be oh great question I'll say
2005 we roasted Pamela Anderson and look
at her now she's President of the United
States 2008 so you can take that fun
fact home with you yeah Mike make sure
to check out Tim's half hour this Friday
at 11:00 on comedy central please like
comment subscribe our other show on
Twitter extra damn day see you tomorrow
[Music]